สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดี
ค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนอีกแล้วนะครับวันนี้
ในวันอะไรคะที่เจอ
ที่ไหนก่อนเจอที่ไหนเจอที่ไหนเจอที่
ไทยครับ
นักเรียนเดาว่าวันอะไร 3  2  1 วันอะไร
ใครตอบได้ comment มาเลยค่ะ
เคยถามนักเรียนบางคนนักเรียนบางคนไม่รู้
นะว่า
ทำไมวันแต่ละวันมีสีด้วยเหรอ
คลิปหน้านะคะเดี๋ยวเราจะเอามาบอกนะคะว่า
วันอะไรสีอะไรแล้วทำไมเราเชื่อแบบนั้นยัง
ไม่ใช่แค่สีนะคะยังมีหินที่ที่แต่ละวัน
ต้องใส่แล้วโชคดี
นะสำหรับสีม่วงเนี่ย
เป็นวันวันวันเสาร์วันเสาร์ใช่แล้ววันนี้
เรามาเจอกันวันเสาร์นะครับวันเสาร์ที่
ชมพู
วันเสาร์สีม่วงที่ 13 เนาะใช่ไหมเดือน
เมษายน
เดือนพฤษภาคมไม่ใช่เดือน
3 ไม่ใช่
สภาคมเมษายน
เลยมาแล้วเลยเมษามาแล้วเป็นพฤษภาคมนะครับ
วันเสาร์ก็มาเจอกับครูเอ๋นี่ไงครับก็เลย
วิ่งไม่ได้วิ่งครับ
คนนะคนเราเนี่ยนักเรียน
ครูเอกก็จะพูดเหมือนอยู่ในคลาสจริงๆเลย
พูดกับครัวตี้บ้างพูดกับนักเรียนบ้างสลับ
กันครับ
จะแข็งแรงเนี่ยก็จะต้องมี 1
นอน
นอนดีๆก็คือหลับสบายๆ
2 ออกกำลังกาย
ประจำประจำก็คือออกมานานๆ
ดูเรื่องอาหาร
กินอาหารอะไรให้แข็งแรง
[เพลง]
ก็สำคัญเหมือนกันใช่ครับ
อาหารไทยเนี่ยกินแล้วแข็งแรงใช่ๆครับ
เพราะว่ากลัวที่คิดว่าอาหารไทยหลายๆอย่าง
เนี่ยเราจะใส่
เรียกว่าอะไร
สมุนไพร
เรียกว่าเครื่องปรุงใช่ไหมหรือส่วนประกอบ
ของอาหารใช่ไหมเรามี
ที่จริงอาหารไทยที่ใส่ก็
เครื่อง
ปรุงมันจะเป็นน้ำปลาเป็นเกลือ
อันนี้เรียกว่า
ส่วนผสมไหมหรือว่าเครื่องแกงถ้าเป็นแกงก็
เรียกว่าเครื่องแกงแต่ว่าถ้าไม่ได้แกง
เป็นต้มเป็นผัดก็วัตถุดิบ
ก็ได้แต่ว่าถ้าตามมาเอามาแล้วตำ
มีครกแล้วก็ตำเราก็เรียกว่าเครื่องแกงนะ
คะเครื่องแกงโอเค
หรือบางทีก็เรียกว่าเป็นน้ำพริกใช่ไหมถ้า
เอามาทำๆๆ
คือวันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้นักเรียนเขาอยากจะนำ
เสนอนำเสนอก็คือเอามาให้นักเรียนดูว่าใน
อาหารไทยของเราเนี่ย
มันมีมีอะไรนะ
เครื่องแกงที่อยู่ในนั้นมีสมุนไพรอะไร
บ้างใช่ซึ่งสมุนไพรพวกนี้กินแล้ว
แข็งแรง
ดีกว่าร่างกายใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ดียังไงมีประโยชน์อะไรกับร่างกายของ
เราที่ใส่สมุนไพรพวกนี้เข้าไปในเครื่อง
แกง
มีอะไรบ้างคะอาหารชนิดแรกเลยที่ควร
ขอโทษค่ะ
จะรู้จักอาหารไทยรู้จักอะไรบ้าง
มีอะไรบ้างวันนี้โคโยตี้เอามานักเรียน
ต้องรู้จักแน่นอนใช่ไหมต้องรู้จักแน่ๆ
ครับผม
เดี๋ยวถ้าให้ดูรูปนะ
นักเรียนยกมือตอบได้เลยนะครับเพราะว่า
อะไร
มาแล้วครับรูปนี้ว้าว
[เพลง]
ไหม
มีนักเรียนบางคนตอบ
มาหรือเปล่า
[เพลง]
นะคะเป็นอะไรคะอ่าอันนี้เป็นกุ้งครับกุ้ง
มีสีส้มสีแดงนะครับแบบนี้นะครับ
[เพลง]
มีเห็ดฟางอยู่ตรงนี้นี่ตรงนี้เป็นเห็ดฟาง
นะครับก็มีผักชี
นี่ครับมีใบมะกรูด
ตะไคร้นี่ครับตะไคร้
นักเรียนอาจจะงงๆนะไม่เห็นดูเลยเดี๋ยว
โคโยตี้มีรูปให้ดูชัดๆนะครับแนะนำก่อนว่า
สิ่งที่อยู่ในป้อมยามเวลานักเรียนสั่งต้ม
ยำมาเนี่ยสิ่งเหล่านี้มันอยู่ในนี้เรา
เรียกว่าอะไรแล้วมันคืออะไร
นี่คือต้มยำต้มยำกุ้งครับ
ทำไมถึงหิว
9:30 นค่ะอ๋อ 9 โมงครึ่งเป็นเวลาที่หิว
ข้าวพอดีเลยแต่ครัวตี้เนี่ยอิ่มอร่อย
ได้ไหม
[เพลง]
คือเป็นอาหารที่คนต่างชาติคือไม่ใช่คนไทย
อ่ะคนอเมริกันคนแคนาดาคนญี่ปุ่นคนเกาหลี
น่าจะรู้จักนะคะน่าจะรู้จัก
ส่วนประกอบที่อยู่ในต้มยำกุ้งที่เป็น
สมุนไพร
พวกนี้เข้าไปในต้มยำกุ้งแล้วเนี่ยมันมี
ประโยชน์อะไรมีประโยชน์อะไรกับร่างกายของ
เราบ้าง
อ๋อมีประโยชน์ไม่ใช่แค่อร่อยใช่ไหมไม่ใช่
แค่อร่อยอร่อยด้วยแล้วก็มีประโยชน์ด้วย
ทั้ง 2 อย่างเลยนะครับ
ขอรู้จักชื่อก่อนนะคะแต่ละอย่างมีอะไร
บ้างคะมาดูอย่างแรกกันก่อนครับอย่างแรก
คืออันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับครูเอก
หอมแดงค่ะ
แต่ตอนใส่เนี่ยนักเรียนเราจะต้องเราจะ
ต้องใช้มีดเนี่ยออกปลอกเปลือกมันออกก่อน
นะ
ผิวแดงๆใช่ผิวแดงๆตรงนี้นี่ๆที่นักเรียน
เห็น
เป็นหอมแดงที่ปอกแล้วก็จะหน้าตาเป็นแบบ
นี้
เวลาปลอกของแดง
น้ำตาไหลต้องร้องไห้ด้วยใช่ไหมครับไม่ใช่
นะ
ใช่ๆเพราะว่าเวลาที่เราปอกหอมแดงเนี่ยเรา
จะมีเขาเรียกว่าอะไรมันมีสารทำให้น้ำตาล
เนี่ยไหลออกมาคือต้องใช้มีดข้างหลังมีมีด
ครับ
[เพลง]
ตัดแล้วออกเลยแล้วถ้ามีดไม่คมน่ะมันจะมี
เล็กๆมันกระเด็นขึ้นมามันเข้าน้ำตาจะไหล
ก็เลยน้ำตาไหลนะครับ
หอมแดง
หอมแดงดีครับหอมแดงมีประโยชน์หลายอย่าง
เลยนะครับอีกอย่างหนึ่งที่ครัวตี้จำได้
เนี่ยประโยชน์ของหอมแดงเนี่ย
มีวิตามินซีใช่ไหม
แล้วก็หอมแดงเนี่ยเราใช้
ได้ด้วยนะแก้หวัดแล้วก็จมูก
คือเวลาเป็นหวัดน่ะเวลาสมมุติว่าเป็นหวัด
นะคะครูเอกเคยเป็นหวัดแล้ว
บอกว่าให้ครูเอ๋อ่ะเอาหอมแดงเยอะๆ
เอาไปต้ม
แล้วก็แล้วก็เอาหน้าเนี่ยดมไอน้ำมันจะมี
ไอน้ำร้อนๆอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ครับโอเคนะ
หม้อเวลาเราเอามาตั้งไฟใช่ไหมไฟอยู่ข้าง
ล่างนี้นะ
[เพลง]
ลงไปก็จะมีไอน้ำขึ้นมา
แล้วก็ให้เราน่ะเอาหน้าเข้าไปแล้วก็สูตร
ไอน้ำขึ้นมา
[เพลง]
แล้วเขาบอกว่ามันจะทำให้อาการที่แน่นจมูก
หายเวลาเราเป็นหวัดเราจะหายใจไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมอันนี้จะหาย
ครูเอกก็เลยซื้อหอมแดงเนี่ย
ครึ่งกิโลกรัม
แล้วก็ไปต้มแล้วก็
สูตรเฉยๆไม่โอเคกินด้วยดีกว่า
ก็เลยทำต้มยำเลย
เพราะว่ามันกินได้หอมแดงกินได้รสใส่ไปใน
อาหารหลายๆอย่างตอนนี้เราก็ใส่ป้องกัน
หวัดค่ะป้องกันหวัดด้วยนะครับป้องกันกับ
รักษาไม่เหมือนกันยังไงค่ะครูอัฐิเมื่อ
ป้องกันก็คือเรายังไม่เป็นหวัดบอกว่าเรา
ป้องกันไว้ก่อนป้องกันที่จะไม่ให้เป็น
หวัดก็คือกินกินหอมแดงนะคะหรือกินพวกนี้
พวกต้มยำอ่ะค่ะแล้วก็
กินอย่างอื่นอีกก็ได้นะคะแล้วเวลา
มีหวัดมาร่างกายก็สู้ได้แล้วก็มี
แต่ถ้ารักษาล่ะคะ
ถ้ารักษาก็คือเราเป็นหวัดแล้วเราเป็นหวัด
แล้วเราก็กินเข้าไปเพื่อให้หอมเนี่ยหัว
หอมแดงเนี่ยเข้าไปช่วยช่วยในการทำให้ร่าง
กายจากที่เป็นหวัดอยู่ค่อยๆดีขึ้นดีขึ้น
แล้วก็หายก็คือการรักษา
งั้นตอนนี้นักเรียนไปหาหอมแดงนะแต่ประเทศ
นักเรียนจะไม่มีหอมแดงลูกเล็กๆนะคะใช้ลูก
ใหญ่ก็ได้นะคะที่เป็นหอมของอินเดียคนไทย
เรียกหอมแขกนะคะใหญ่ๆกว่านี้สีแดงสีแดง
เหมือนกันนะครับใส่ใหญ่กว่าใช่ก็ใช้ได้นะ
คะแต่ว่าของนักเรียนอาจจะมีหอมใหญ่
หอมใหญ่จะสีขาวนะสีขาวก็ใช้ได้อยู่ใช้ได้
อยู่แต่หอมแดงเรารู้สึกว่าหอมแดงดีกว่า
เพราะว่าเราเรา
คนไทยกินหอมแดงเป็นประจำกินหอมแดงบ่อยๆนะ
ครับเพราะฉะนั้นอันนี้โอเคหาง่ายแล้วก็
กินได้ครับ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็มีอะไรอีกครับเมื่อกี้ที่อยู่ใน
ถ้วย
อ่าเห็นตะไคร้หรือเปล่าคะ
นี่ๆ
เดี๋ยวกลับไปชี้ให้นักเรียนดูก่อนตะไคร้
อยู่ตรงไหน
อันนี้ใช่ไหมนี่ตะไคร้นะครับเอาจริงๆกิน
ได้ไหม
ครัวตี้ก็เคี้ยวเล่นๆนะเชียวเล่นๆแต่ว่า
ไม่กินเข้าไปนะ
ธรรมดาก่อนนะเวลาที่เราใส่ในต้มยำเนี่ยก็
คือจะทำให้กลิ่นกลิ่นหอมหอมตะไคร้เนี่ยจะ
ทำให้
กลิ่นของกุ้งกลิ่นของปลากลิ่นของไก่เนี่ย
น้อยลง
เราเรียกว่าดับกลิ่นนะคะ
[เพลง]
กุ้งปลาไก่เราบอกว่าเป็นกลิ่นคาว
กินข้าวของของสัตว์ก็จะใช้ตะไคร้ใช้ข่า
คือสมุนไพรเนี่ยจะดับกลิ่นให้กลิ่นนม
สมุนไพรหอมกว่าใช่ซึ่งบางคนก็เลยบอกว่า
ไม่ต้องกินแต่กินได้นะ
ครับถ้าเราหั่นบางๆอ๋อหั่นเป็นชิ้นเล็กๆ
ใช่ไหมเป็นชิ้นเล็กๆๆกินได้ต้องเรียกว่า
ซอยเนอะไม่ใช่หั่น
ซอยเพราะทหารมันจะใหญ่หน่อยซอยบ้างบาง
กว่านี้อีกนะ
กินได้เลยแต่ถ้ามาใหญ่ๆเนี่ย
ก็เคี้ยวๆแล้วก็เอาออกนะคะ
นักเรียนบางคน
ก็จะมีรสชาติของตะไคร้รสชาติของสมุนไพร
เอ้อออกจากนิดหน่อยแต่ไม่เหมือนกับพริก
พริกที่เผ็ดนะครับเป็นเผ็ดของตะไคร้ถ้า
ยังไม่เคยลองเลยลองเคี้ยวเล่นๆได้
ครูเอกเคยไปกินข้าวกับนักเรียนหลายคนนัก
เรียนหนักแล้วเคี้ยวๆแล้วก็พยายามจะกลืน
อ่ะแล้วนักเรียน
ทำไมกลืนไม่ได้
ไม่ต้องกลืนนะคะเขียวแล้วก็เอาออกแต่ถ้า
เล็กๆบางๆอันนี้ขี่รถกลืนได้นะคะใช่
นะแต่ใครก็ดีใช่มั้ยคะ
ตะไคร้เนี่ยเอ่อช่วยรักษาอาการของการท้อง
อืดได้ครับใช่รักษาอาการท้องอืดแล้วก็ปวด
ท้องแล้วก็ช่วยในเรื่องของเอ่อความดัน
โลหิตสูงได้ด้วยนะครับใครเนี่ยท้องอืด
เนี่ยเป็นยังไงนะ
ท้องอืดใช่ไหมท้องอืดก็เหมือนเวลาเรากิน
อาหารเข้าไปเยอะๆๆอาหารเวลาเข้าไปอยู่ใน
ท้องเนี่ยมันก็มันก็ขยายตัวขึ้นทำให้รู้
สึกอึดอัดเพราะว่าข้างในเนี่ยข้างในท้อง
เรามันใหญ่ขึ้นแล้วก็มีแก๊ส
เราก็รู้สึกมันไม่ย่อยอาหารมันมันไม่เล็ก
ลงอ่ะมันอยู่ในท้องอ่ะนักเรียนอาหารแบบ
กินไก่เข้าไปไก่ก็ไก่ก็อยู่ในท้องไก่ไม่
เล็กๆแล้วก็
ปวดท้อง
เรียกว่าท้องอืด
ก็กินตะไคร้เข้าไปก็ช่วยใช่ไหมให้แบบช่วย
ได้
ทำให้มีลมออกไป
ลดลมลดอาการท้องอืดนะครับลดแก๊สในกระเพาะ
อาหาร
ช่วยเรื่องอะไรนะความดันโลหิตความดัน
โลหิตสูงถ้าความดันปกติประมาณเท่าไหร่คะ
ถ้าความดันปกติใช่ไหม
ขีด
ก็ได้ขีดขีด
[เพลง]
120 ใช่ไหมครับ
ตัวล่างเนี่ย 80 บนเนี่ย 120 แต่ถ้าสูงนะ
คะจะเท่าไหร่
ถ้าสูงตัวนี้ค่าตัวนี้ก็จะสูงขึ้นกว่านี้
อาจจะเป็นอาจจะเป็นเท่าไหร่ครับ
150  130  150
ก็จะรู้ว่าความดันสูง
ไม่ดีใช่ไหม
มีประโยชน์ในการช่วยช่วยลดความดันได้ต่ำ
ลงได้นะครับ
เราเรียกว่าสรรพคุณก็ได้เนาะใช่สรรพคุณ
หรือว่าคุณประโยชน์นะครับจะใช้คำว่า
สรรพคุณคุณประโยชน์หรือมีประโยชน์ได้หมด
นะคะใช่ครับแต่ถ้าเป็น
ประโยชน์ในทางยาเราก็จะเรียกว่าสรรพคุณ
สรรพคุณหอมแดงมีสรรพคุณในการแก้หวัดใช้มี
สรรพคุณในการลดความดันโลหิตสูง
ไม่ใช่แค่ไม่ใช่เป็นอาหารเฉยๆแต่กินแล้ว
ไม่ต้องกินยา
กินแล้วมีประโยชน์ในด้านของการป้องกันนะ
ครับทำให้ร่างกายแข็งแรงด้วยนะครับ
ตะไคร้
คุณสมบัติของสมุนไพรว่าทำอะไรได้บ้างแต่
ว่าตะไคร้เราก็เอาไปทำเครื่องดื่มได้
โอเคตะไคร้ตะไคร้มีไวตามินด้วยนะคะนัก
เรียน
ใช่ครับใช่ครับ
มีอะไรมาดูว่า
ส่วนประกอบนะครับเครื่องแกงชนิดต่อไป
อันนี้ครับอันนี้
ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ตรงนี้ครับอ่อนๆตรงนี้ครับ
เพราะว่าขาจะช่วยย่อยอาหาร
อยากจะ
ให้ดูน้ำอะไรนะมันมีอะไรนะ
คือคนไทยบอกว่าข่าเนี่ยเข้าไปเรากินขา
ปั๊บขาก็ไปทำให้ร่างกายเราเนี่ย
ย่อยอาหารย่อยอาหาร
มาทำงานทำงาน
บางทีร่างกายเราเนี่ยกินอาหารแล้วก็อาหาร
อยู่ที่นี่
ไม่ย่อยกินอะไรนะ
กินแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ก็แฮมเบอร์เกอร์อยู่ที่
นี่ก็ใหญ่ขึ้นไม่เล็กลงเล็กลงความกินข่า
จริงๆมีอย่างอื่นอีกนะคะเป็นทีมเข้าไปก็
จะบอกร่างกาย
เอาน้ำอาหารมาแล้ว
ข้างในจะมีน้ำสีเขียวๆน้ำย่อยออกมาแล้วก็
ย่อย
ทำให้อาหารที่ชิ้นใหญ่น่ะเล็กลงเล็กลง
เล็กลงนะคะ
ก็คือช่วยย่อยอาหารนั่นเองช่วยทำให้ระบบ
การย่อยอาหารในกระเพาะของเราเนี่ยดีขึ้น
แล้วก็รถแก๊สด้วยนะคะ
อ่าเดี๋ยวเรามาดูเครื่องปรุงต่อไปนะครับ
เวลาเราเหลืออีกประมาณ 7 นาทีครบป้อมยาม
ไปครับ
ไปที่มะนาวดีกว่า
มะนาวมีประโยชน์อะไรค่ะมะนาวเนี่ยมะนาว
นอกจากจะเปรี้ยวแล้วทำให้อาหารอร่อยเนี่ย
กลัวตี้ชอบอาหารเปรี้ยวชอบรสเปรี้ยวแล้ว
นอกจากทำให้อาหารเปรี้ยวแล้วก็อร่อยแล้ว
เนี่ยมะนาวยังช่วยแก้วิงเวียนศีรษะได้
ด้วย
ใช่ครับวิงเวียนศีรษะก็คืออย่างเช่นเรา
ทีมงานแล้วเรารู้สึกว่า
ทำไม
เหมือน
นั่งไม่ตรงใช่ไหม
มะนาวมะนาวจะมีกลิ่นหอมช่วยอ่าคุณช่วยให้
ลดอาการวิงเวียนศีรษะได้ครับสรรพคุณของ
มะนาวมีไวตามินซีด้วยนะใช่มีไวตามินซีสูง
เพราะว่ามีรถเปรี้ยว
ผลไม้หรือว่าสัตว์ที่มีรสเปรี้ยวก็ส่วน
ใหญ่ก็จะมีไวตามินซีเนี่ยสูงนะครับช่วยทำ
ให้
ลดอาการวิงเวียนศีรษะนะครับช่วยเพิ่มความ
สดชื่นนะครับตายนะครับ
แล้วมีอะไรอีก
มีอะไรอีกใช่ไหมครับในในอ้อสำคัญเลยอัน
นี้สำคัญมากลืมไม่ได้เลยถ้าเราต้มยำเนี่ย
ไม่ใส่อันนี้ไม่ได้นะอะไรนะ
ครับ
เพิ่มความเผ็ด
นอกจากนอกจากพริกขี้หนูจะเผ็ดแล้วเนี่ย
ยังมีประโยชน์อย่างอื่นด้วยนะยังไงนะครับ
ประโยชน์ของพริกเนี่ยที่เราใส่พริกเข้าไป
เนี่ยจะทำให้
ติ๊กเนี่ยจะช่วยลดคอเลสเตอรอลในร่างกาย
ได้ด้วยนะ
ก็แสดงว่าทำให้ความดันลดลง
ส่วนช่วยกันครับช่วยกันถ้าคอเลสเตอรอลลด
ลงความดันก็ต้องลดลง
[เพลง]
แล้วก็พลิกก็ช่วยให้
เขาบอกเนี่ยเขาเรียกว่าอะไรดี
คือทำให้กลิ่นอาหารอร่อย
อาจจะสนุกกับคนไทยนะหรือสำหรับบางคนที่
กินเผ็ดนะบางคนที่กินเผ็ดชอบกินเผ็ดก็
ต้องใส่พริกด้วยอย่างโคโยตี้เนี่ยโคโยตี้
เวลากินอาหารเนี่ยก็ชอบชอบที่จะใส่ใส่
พริกด้วยเพราะทำอาหารให้อาหารเนี่ยอร่อย
ขึ้น
จริงๆแล้วที่บอกว่าทำให้รู้สึกกินอาหาร
อร่อยอ่ะเพราะว่าพริกก็ช่วยย่อยเหมือนกัน
ใช่ๆๆก็ช่วยอีกย่อยด้วยเหมือนกันแต่อร่อย
แล้วก็
แล้วก็ถ้าจะกินได้เยอะขึ้น
เขาเรียกว่าเวลาเห็นอาหารแล้วมันมีน้ำลาย
แล้ว
มีรสเปรี้ยวอ่ะ
มันจะทำให้มีน้ำลายอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ค่ะเขาก็มีไวตามินนะคะ
ที่ช่วยให้เราเรารู้สึกว่าน้ำย่อยเนี่ยทำ
งานได้ดี
[เพลง]
บอกว่ากินอาหารอร่อยขึ้นแต่ที่แน่ๆกิน
แล้วรู้สึกร้อน
เหงื่อออก
เพราะว่ามันเผ็ดใช่ไหม
นอกจากช่วยลดคอเลสเตอรอลช่วยให้อาหาร
อร่อยเนี่ยช่วยให้หายใจได้สะดวกขึ้นด้วย
นะ
ใช่ครับเพราะว่าเวลากินพริกแล้วเรารู้สึก
หายใจง่ายขึ้นใช่ไหม
ครับ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเรากินต้มยำแล้วเนี่ยเราจะมีกลิ่นหอมๆ
กลิ่นหอมมาจากอันนี้มาจากอันนี้
อ่ามาจากใบมะกรูดครับ
รูปใบมะกรูดชัดๆเผื่อนักเรียนยังไม่เคย
เห็นนี่
นี่คือใบมะกรูดนะครับอ่านี่เป็นต้นของ
มะกรูดแต่ที่มะกรูดก็จะมีใบอันนี้คือใบ
ที่เป็นผมหอมที่เราเอามาใส่ในต้มยำนะครับ
ไม่ใส่ได้ไหมใบมะกรูด
มันจะไม่หอมถ้าไม่ใส่ก็ได้ครับแต่ถ้าไม่
ใส่แล้วไม่หอมถ้าใส่หอมกว่าแล้วเราจะรู้
สึกว่าต้มยำ
ใส่ใบมะกรูดด้วยถ้าเป็นใบอ่อนๆนะคะนัก
เรียนคือใบใบนิ่มๆอ่ะค่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วมีประโยชน์อะไรคะใบมะกรูดใบมะกรูด
เนื่องจากมันมีกลิ่นมีความหอมอยู่ในกลิ่น
ของใบมะกรูดเนี่ยก็จะเป็นเอ่อมีสารที่
ช่วยคลายความเครียดได้ในใบมะกรูดนะครับ
อ่า
มีความสุขนะครับไม่มีไม่เครียดนะครับลด
อาการเครียดได้แล้วก็เอ่อมีสรรพคุณทางอีก
อย่างหนึ่งก็คือช่วยแก้อาการช้ำในได้ชั้น
ในเป็นยังไงอ่ะ
เหมือนเอ่อเป็นความเรียกว่าอะไรครับ
ข้างในเจ็บ
อยู่ข้างในเจ็บอยู่ข้างในอันนี้เรียกว่า
ช้ำในและข้างนอกน่ะข้างนอกน่ะ
1 วัน 2 วันหายแล้วแต่ข้างในยังเจ็บอยู่
ทำไง
ช้ำอยู่ข้างในใช่ไหมครับใบมะกรูดก็จะไป
ช่วยนะครับ
ซ่อมแซมส่วนที่ป่วนอยู่ข้างในให้หายให้ดี
ขึ้นนะครับ
สรุปแล้วยังมีอีกไหมคะ
กินอะไรนะต้มยำแล้วลูก
รู้สึกสบายนะคะถ้าใครไม่กินเผ็ดก็ไม่ต้อง
ใส่พริกไม่ต้องใส่พริกได้หรือว่าใส่พริก
นิดหน่อยได้ 1 เม็ด 2 เม็ดได้นะครับแต่
ว่าถ้ากินแล้วเอ๊ะทำไมอาหารอร่อยทำไมท้อง
ท้องเบาๆไม่แน่นไม่หนักก็เพราะว่าผักทั้ง
หมดที่เราใส่ลงไปเนี่ยจะทำให้
ท้องไม่อืดแล้วบ๊ายบาย
ช่วยย่อยอาหารได้ด้วยนะครับใช่เราก็มี
ไวตามินเยอะมากนะคะ
แต่ต้องเป็นบีบมะนาวจริงๆ
[เพลง]
ที่โรยข้างหน้าก็มีไวตามินเอนะคะ
โอเควันนี้ก็เราแนะนำต้มยำกุ้งอย่างเดียว
เองนะครับได้อย่างเดียวไม่เป็นไรเวลาหมด
ซะแล้วเดี๋ยวเอาหน้าถ้ามีโอกาสจะมาแนะนำ
อาหารไทยอย่างอื่นที่ใส่สมุนไพรเข้าไปนะ
ครับที่เราไม่ได้แนะนำให้นักเรียนบอกว่า
อันนี้อร่อยแต่เราจะบอกมากในอาหารอันนั้น
เนี่ยมีอะไรบ้างที่กินแล้วร่างกายแข็งแรง
นะคะ
[เพลง]
ใช่หมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวเราสองคนต้องลาไป
ก่อนเดี๋ยวมาเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้าครับ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีครับนัก
เรียน
บ๊ายบาย